-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show!"
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
everybody is talking about this.
Last night, CBS aired
a two-hour special
called "Adele: One Night Only."
Yep. The special brought in
10 million viewers.
CBS heard and was like, "Sorry.
We meant '100 Nights Only.'
Sorry."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, more people watched
Adele's special than the Oscars.
Although more people
are watching their
Ring doorbell cameras
than the Oscars.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, that's right.
In the special,
Adele opened up about
the pain of her divorce.
It was tough to sit through.
Right after, I had to re-watch
"Squid Game"
just to lighten my mood.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Adele said that she knew
she needed to end her marriage
when she was doing
a magazine quiz.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Even crazier, it was Buzzfeed's
"Which character from
'Hocus Pocus' are you?"
[ Laughter ]
You can tell everyone at CBS
was excited about Adele.
Check out the beginning
of "60 Minutes" last night.
[ Watch ticking ]
-♪ Go easy on me, baby ♪
-Oh.
[ Watch ticking ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was at the beginning?
I didn't see the beginning.
-Wow!
-Let's get to some news.
Today, President Biden
finally signed
his $1.2 trillion
infrastructure bill.
Yep. Now we all get one day
to celebrate before America
turns into one
giant construction site.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, by the time
we actually fix all the roads,
everyone will be riding
in drones.
[ Laughter ]
I'm excited about the bill.
I mean, soon we can stop
making the sign of the cross
before driving over
the George Washington Bridge.
[ Laughter ]
"All right, I love you guys.
You know that, right?"
Some more political news.
Today, Beto O'Rourke released
a video officially launching his
campaign for governor of Texas.
Watch this.
-I'm running for governor,
and I want to tell you why.
I want you on the team,
and I want to win this with you
and for you and for all
the people of Texas.
-Your aunt was like,
"Until 'Bridgerton' comes back,
this is as good as it gets."
[ Laughter ]
Can we see Beto again?
Forget governor.
He looks like he should be
selling homemade honey
at a farmers market.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Two -- Two for 10 bucks?"
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
I heard that Costco just
warned its customers
of a potential data breach
after they found a credit-card
skimmer in one of their stores.
Or, as the thief put it, "I just
bought some identities in bulk."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's hard to spot
credit-card fraud at a Costco,
'cause every purchase seems
like a strange purchase.
It's like, "What's that?
$5,000 on cheeseballs?"
[ Laughter ]
"That actually was me.
Sorry.
Okay, yeah, that was me.
Sorry."
[ Laughter ]
"My kids are playing in
one of the cheeseball containers
right now. It's awesome."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that Gucci
is releasing a special edition
Xbox that comes
with two controllers
and a branded suitcase
for $10,000.
Check this thing out.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right. Great.
Right after I just spent
12 grand
on a Chanel PlayStation.
-Oh.
-You know?
[ Laughter ]
-Seriously, for 10 grand,
a Gucci Xbox should come
with Adam Driver and Lady Gaga.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know what I'm saying?
Well, get this -- a new poll
found that, due to rising costs,
nearly half of Americans
will soon cancel at least
one of their
streaming subscriptions.
You know as soon as
you cancel Netflix,
you're gonna hear your neighbor
scream through the wall,
"What the hell?"
You go...
[ Laughter ]
"I was almost done
with 'Squid Game'!"
"Sorry."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is very exciting.
This weekend,
the Rockefeller Center Christmas
tree arrived in New York City.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right outside.
And I know what everyone
is thinking.
Yes, the tree
has been vaccinated.
[ Laughter ]
What's crazy is, this is
actually last year's tree.
It just got here now
'cause of supply-chain issues.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, border officials
in the U.K.
found $44 million
worth of cocaine
hidden in a shipment
of onion rings.
[ Laughter ]
Yep.
$44 million in onion rings,
plus another million
in the one french fry
that was in there by mistake.